ah we're doing it guys I'm going are we
on we're on
what's up playas hey it's Kate this is
date fails we're back in the studio
we're on the YouTube stream for those of
you watching on YouTube
here we are by the way for those of you
watching on YouTube just so you know
when the episode is not on YouTube it is
still on iTunes and SoundCloud so you
can still listen to it people message me
every week they're like why didn't you
do it this week I'm like it's up it's
just audio sometimes I look like crap so
I don't want to be on camera if I cried
all day can I tell you guys something
real
last Friday though I did not put an
episode out so I I made up for it by
popping one up on like Tuesday I think
and people were like why didn't you and
I'm gonna tell you the truth you know I
didn't do one last Friday you had like I
said I had a no I was depressed I was so
depressed why didn't you call me well I
don't I mean I know well I did I could
have I just I was like fighting with
this guy for so many days and I was like
I can't go on the podcast right now
because i'm just gonna [ __ ] the whole
time yeah so i've never done that before
where but then i started thinking maybe
i should have done it and got come on
and cried it probably would have got the
best ratings just me sobbing and
drinking tequila in the middle of the
day therapeutic i did i did one with my
friend Kaitlyn and I brought those
little airplane bottles of I think it
was like Jack Daniels or something it
was just one of those days and I I don't
really do shots I just drink wine so I I
was even extra that day and I remember
we recorded we were talking about the
Son of Sam and at the end of it she was
like we can't use any of that like you
just progressively got drunker and
Saturn no way even before we started
she's like are you sure you want to do
this Mike no it's gonna be good it's
gonna be fine
I'll work through it this would be good
for me it was so bad that she's like we
have to scrap it red van and I recorded
an episode of date fails in Alaska after
we partied until 4:30 in the morning and
then we decided to go back to the hotel
and record it and we did post it but if
you listen to it both of us sound so
[ __ ] up like we're talking
what's slurring our words we're like
talking slow it's uh but it's really
honest but then after that we decided to
try to record an episode of his old
podcast which is called dysentery that
he used to do and he stopped doing it
and he was like let's bring back
dysentery and it's like the dirtiest
part you just talk dirty the whole time
but we were both so drunk exactly but we
were both so drunk we started to get
like sentimental and then we started
talking about like our parents and
growing up in ojai and it got like
really deep and the next day Brian
listen to it he's like we're not posting
so sometimes you can't use it happens
guys let me introduce my guest this is
an all-girls episode which has yeah I
love the all-girls I wish we had drinks
I should have brought drinks what's
wrong with me drinks I know Carrie
showed up with what did you sure I was
like I'm running late fireball I stopped
at a CVS to grab a ball Jack Daniels
which Kris red took home and then I had
the again a four pack of wine
thanks I'm a lady she is it was a
classic I think it was boxed wine no
wasn't it like wine in a box no just
like the little like flight bottles oh
you're right they're plastic it'll
Sutter home yes well Kerry shows up
today okay so first of all my guest here
I have two one is my very dear friend
I've known you for years probably almost
longer than any girls that I know in
comedy like at least five years
um which comedy years is like we've
known each other yeah years three dog
years
uh carrie has one of my favorite podcast
white wine true crime which I've done
many times where we watch crime TV shows
and drink and then make jokes about them
which I love and now you have another
podcast it's doing really well called
pretty scary cracked what is that one
about so it started off where we were
talking about things that were pretty
scary in Los Angeles like the Cecil
Hotel the endless national forest guys
big body dump place STDs now it's mature
things that are pretty scary AIDS we've
talked about AIDS about rappers we've
talked about searing gaffers
rappers are part of the pretty scary
yeah yeah so yeah we've talked about the
Cecil Hotel rappers and sarin gas so
there you go did you have it sarin sarin
gas is like a gas like you die what like
why I got in LA did an episode it's you
remember the movie The Rock yeah this
cage
yeah that's the gas that's real world
right I mean I don't think anyone's
actually used well they stay accused
Syria of using it
yeah I don't know we did a whole episode
and I still can't really explain it you
should you should do an episode about
the sign they have up in like every
Starbucks and coffee bean in California
that says yeah it says if you eat or
drink in this establishment like
materials have been known to cause
cancer and they're all over there in
like every Starbucks in California and I
want to know what at the Starbucks is
causing cancer so that I can enjoy a
show that's pretty scary that is scary
but you should do that episode I like
that so Kerry Martin everyone check her
out it's at Kerry Martin 22 on Instagram
I'm sorry Kerry Martin 7:22 on Twitter
because I really got to get that fixed
you gotta put that together I love you
and Kerry also showed up today straight
from 7-eleven with a with a UFC wake up
so we have the UFC cups now at 7-eleven
and product placement Kerry also works
for 7-eleven FYI you're like we she owns
a 7-eleven but on no I don't know I like
a district manager for them so I visit
7-elevens all day and so like this month
and next month we cooperated with the
UFC which the cups only have like the
the mitts where they're you know getting
ready to fight but on the fountain
there's like three fighters and every
time I pass by it I always wonder which
one's of those Kate slept with Carrie I
haven't slept with many fighters I've
only slept with one fighter but I bet
it's one of them and which have been fun
though I mean look at that I have a
thing for fighters like I've got I've
made out with three but I've only
slept with one but I will say that like
there's just something about them
because they're like like tough yeah and
you know if someone starts some [ __ ]
with you they can just like you know I'm
friends with Rampage Jackson and we've
never hooked up but like there's
something so hot cuz we'll be talking
and he's goofy and he's just like a
goofy cuddly like teddy bear type guy
the way I know him right you know but
then sometimes every once a while
someone will like like the other night
we were hanging out and there was a guy
kind of across the bar and he was kind
of giving around page a look that
rampage didn't like and then the guy
came over to say hi and rampage just
stared him down like it was the guy came
over and and the guy wasn't super nice
like if he's nice rampage will be nice
back but the guy came over but he was
saying hi but he was kind of like yo man
like my my dude over there you know he
says you're the [ __ ] whatever but the
guy was kind of I don't know he was a
little aggressive whatever it was
rampage didn't like about it he just
stared the guy down until the guy kind
of got quiet and walked off and I was
like that's hot that is kind of hot
right yeah anyway on to the next so my
other guest today I have to say and this
is no offense to any of my girlfriends
but of all my girlfriends you were the
hardest to take out am i yes because
when I take this girl out I get zero
male attention whatsoever no I get
different you're like the hot blonde I'm
just like you're so hot you need said
that when I posted our photos from your
birthday so she had a birthday party at
the where were we the dream hotel yeah
it was a highlight room highlight
highlight room yeah I post the photos I
swear to God I get a lot of dm's
I got like 50,000 DMS from guys being
like who's your friend
even I got text I got text from guys
that are like guys I've been trying to
date who's your friend
yes that totally happened so anyway but
what I love about you is as gorgeous as
you are and you are and she's like right
now you're in the running for what
Maxim's hottest finest or something
Maxim's finest and you've been on the
cover of Maxim and you're also hilarious
and you have this
amazing radio show that you do which I
actually have been on now it's fine with
chewy with chewy you nice and chewy and
now you're doing the source TV yes yes
so now I have a new show called the
source TV it's on the iHeartRadio app
now you're gonna see it on full screen
coming soon so I'm just watch it like
watch out for it on my social media I'll
be posting like updates on it but it's
fun like we talk about interesting
topics kind of similar we're saying like
crazy things that happen so we try to be
like newsworthy like vice like the show
vice on Vice man yeah um but we also try
to keep a pop-culture fun kind of like a
twist of MTV so we'll talk about weird
subjects of like I don't know like we
just said why is Starbucks always
posting this but it could cause cancer
but we're like [ __ ] it we're still gonna
buy my espresso it's 9:00 a.m. I need
air or whatever so it's kind of like
that mentality of news where we do that
research is fun my coasts Mary we have a
good time I'm on it I don't know watch
it whatever it's fine
but you're so great because you're so
hot and you're so beautiful but you're
also like one of the nicest people like
you're such a sweetheart like a lot of
hot girls are like really vapid or when
they're this hot you don't really cover
of Maxim hot
yeah my true though it's true though and
you've gotten hotter since I since I met
you but yeah somebody has a good
personality
on top it makes them even more
attractive I agree you and I also do
think we should date we talked about
this at your birthday wouldn't we be a
great lesbian couple would you would be
and I do feel like you're definitely
bicurious me yes I just got it you need
say I don't get that bicurious by but I
do get it from Kate you do yeah he's
going to drop something until like he
needs his drink and then like I would
not roofie her she would do it willingly
would you be willing Lee I think I don't
know if I'm bicurious I mean because I
kind of have hooked up with a girl sort
of well I think then you were curious
yeah but I wasn't I was on Holly
they're like but they will connect so
well don't they do really like
everyone's experience something yeah
yeah I've never been so girl and I
dabbled but I've never hooked up with a
girl alone I've only hooked up with a
girl when there's a guy involved so I
don't think that makes you bicurious I
think that makes you just wanting to
impress the guy but now
but you still did stuff with about the
guy there huh no I did do stuff with her
in the moment but only because I knew it
would turn on the guy I know a lot of
girls who are just like strictly dickly
like they won't do anything that doesn't
involve a penis it's like they would
never even kiss a girl I like masculine
men so yeah I'm like I know you're
seeing what the UFC fighters say when
you see like a masculine man like oh
he's so high like I don't know pick me
up and like save me I don't know do you
like that like mentality we have as a
kid like masculinity when guys can pick
you up and like throw you around during
sex that's like my favorite thing
mm-hmm that is my that's why I think
women are so attractive like big hulking
guys cuz you see them and subconsciously
you're like that guy could throw me
around by the way I do have to I have to
talk about something that came up the
other day and see what you guys think so
I was talking about this really hot guy
who I've hung out with on a number of
occasions I'm really attracted to him we
Fleur we we text flirt but every time we
hang out I kind of like hint hint
that I'd like to hook up and he never
takes the bait so I couldn't figure it
out I'm like maybe has a girlfriend I
don't know what the situation is did you
want to date him or just hook up I don't
know this guy doesn't live here he's
someone that doesn't live here but he
comes here pretty often and went and we
text and I would say were friends but
sometimes it gets a little flirty
although since he shot me down three
times I've stopped flirting okay you
know you start to feel stupid maybe the
first time he could be intimidated
because you're beautiful maybe he's like
oh oh she's hot like I know right but
three times maybe he does have someone
or he could be gay well so I'm telling
my friend my guy friend about this and
he goes he's gay and I go but here's the
thing I know women he's hooked up with
and the women that he has hooked up with
were like he was so good in bed he
lasted forever and and my friend Jackson
goes well yeah gay guys are the best
lovers for women because they last
forever cuz they can't come if this guy
is your friend then he also might know
how you have crazy
tendencies I don't know what you mean
it's trying to be PC but okay well okay
well okay that's fair but what do you
think about putting it mildly but what
do you think about this gig I've never
heard that before about gay guys do you
think that that have you ever hooked up
with a guy you think might be gay I
don't know I mean I've I've dated a guy
that was kind of like really trendy like
GQ femme and I kind of questioned it
then but I kind of rhymed GQ friend
she's a rapper everyone I don't know you
know it's hard to say la is tricky man
it city a lot of men here have issues
they got things going on and then you
date them it's been a few months and
you're like what yeah like what yeah I
guess what about you do you think you've
ever hooked up with a gay guy uh yet
well yes I do I think I hooked up with
one in college only man well I think I
am dated but he just had feminine
tendencies he was like one of those guys
who like loved hanging out with the
girls like I was in a sorority and he
was in a fraternity and he got a [ __ ]
stamp of are like sorority like I was so
I'd like three triangles and like a
Poseidon with like one of those like
spheres or whatever I got a [ __ ] stamp
of the sorority though not the
fraternity crap and it was correct yes
and we had snacks you like me to wear
like my like my dolphin necklace because
that was like a football team or a
dolphin animal dolphin that was like
Delta Delta Delta and that was like our
animal that was like our mascot so wait
he could only get off if you were
wearing a dolphin necklace he was like
he was into it yeah all right I'm not
sure that makes him gay super gay you do
yeah so did he last a super long time
and the girls were like he always loved
to come to the sorority house is always
helping us fix things but then like if
we were like doing facials like he would
be like oh like I'll take a facial oh my
gosh yeah no that's weird
or maybe it's Metro I don't know well I
don't know because the lines are so
blurred now I mean I've dated guys like
I dated a guy who would always buy me
clothes and
like fashion sense was so much better
than mine everything he would give me
was so cute it's really nice clothes why
aren't you dating him he was a cheater
it's such a bummer because the pros and
cons sometimes I feel like everyone
cheats isn't that bad it is a day it's
like you just gotta figure it out like
how many good qualities you have right
look and achieve so many people just
don't want to know
it's so sad you're saying this because I
totally agree with you it's like for
instance I've dated like sometimes
really sweet like boy next door can I
dudes I'm like this guy would never
checked and then I hear from someone
like avoids but mind you they are really
good-looking boys are grabs
yeah good-looking guys are trouble but
yeah nevertheless you just don't know
you don't know I do think that everyone
cheats now my thing is like if you're
gonna cheat on me these are my
parameters sheet out of state or at
least she'll be area codes at least
cheat in a way that like okay you'll
never know I will never find a picture
of you and a girl
thank you Instagram like this guy that
I'm talking about her tag settings okay
yeah this guy that I'm talking about
would like pictures are you liking know
that I don't know funny yet it's so true
yeah I stay out of that I don't look I
literally that is my one that's what's
funny if people say I'm crazy I'm only
crazy with texting but I'm really good
about not social media stalking I don't
look I mean this guy that I just ended
things with or whatever we I've never
ever ever look at his Instagram I've
looked at it like once since I've met a
I just don't look I have good willpower
about that interesting if I could apply
that to texting I'd be like killing a
game busy or maybe the Wi-Fi is little
spotty sometimes I think it's because I
what I don't know can't hurt me ignorant
is bliss okay but I joined self as well
like cover my ears yeah I'm just saying
if you're gonna cheat don't like this
guy that cheated on me he would post
photos of like other girls sitting on
his lap at a club so here's my issue
it's not about you cheating it's about
you making me look like an idiot because
people know we're dating and then they
see you post that now I look like a girl
with a boyfriend that has
their chicks sitting on his lap which
makes me look like a loser it's all God
doesn't care about you enough where he
would post it it's like yeah do you need
a post that like he's trying to show
like how cool he is or that he's so got
it right yeah all right here's another
wonderful here's what I want to know so
enough about me let's talk about your
love life
are you both single yes I'm currently
single I met a guy on your birthday was
so hot I know my ex-boyfriend oh he was
your ex well I mean we were all so drunk
we were we're good friends we're good
friends we're working it out so who
knows maybe we we might get theirs
together chill I love that yeah we're
working out we'll see what happens he is
hot and he was really into you I know
well my problem is I always date hot
guys and probably an awful problem to
have it is a problem because all the
girls want them that's the problem so
you're like does it make you insecure no
no I does not make me insecure okay I
actually love it I love it when a girl
checks out my guy like yeah he's mine so
cool you know I'm I'm very confident I
just don't like you what guy what guy is
with Anita and looking around the room
they can hear with you you're with the
hottest girl in the room
no you're so sweet it's the truth you
guys are gonna get it in tonight I know
he's a good guy but you know we're both
so young so I I totally get it he has
temptations or whatever he plays
basketball he's good-looking
we're both Hispanic we've a lot in
common but at the same time it happens
right we're both young so we're figuring
it out we're figuring it out seeing how
it goes
would you ever date Chuy Bravo Chuy my
co-host from yeah I know chewy chewy so
chewy
you know no a not chewy to me I see him
as like not to be weird because I know
he's a little perv but I see was like a
like an uncle or someone he's not like
the he's like the fun crazy uncle in the
family do you know what I mean I'll have
that relative that's we reminds me of
because I bring around my friends music
oh give me Harden um but I dressed up as
Chelsea Handler for Halloween one time
and I rented a little person to be
Chewie you rinse it right
call me I'd be like no I usually would
have saved me $400 I rent it I think
it's a they have a price instead of
saying I rented a little person you
should say I hired hey did you make out
with the with the guy that you hired to
play Chewie on Halloween no no he was he
was married to a little person and they
had a little person daughter
but then he well first of all he pulled
up in like a 98 Ford Taurus which is
fine but it when he opens the door like
he had full on pedal extenders yeah it
was so cute like a little like highchair
or whatever that he was sitting in but
no the next day he sends me an email
telling me that he thought we were soul
mates
no yeah he was married right and he
would like ass call me out you'd ask
little ones the ones that you think will
like never wait on you right he'd be
like send me a picture I fight me it was
crazy I should've stayed married you
guys my ex would have never cheated but
I think though they have the same penis
size like them and they do turn people's
bad well I've seen he's Brad's his big
Brad's is like the size of his head and
he has a big head right brad has I don't
and it's not just because he's a little
person it's like a good size I've only
seen it because like it's not like
necessarily proportional like it's a
good size for being a good son yeah yeah
and it's like people talk about it it's
out there in the community people are
like Brad Williams I heard like it's
true awesome yeah yeah anyone gradual
ations to his new bride well that's
interesting so you're single Carrie
you're single my single I'm always
single - all right well I have questions
I know where's the box of wine like
what's up I know right
you said I do have a bottle opener in my
um my purse oh but no bottles yeah it
doesn't help us um I just have a pair of
flip-flops I had a bottle opener on the
bottom rail in the bottom of the shoe in
Cabo I know
okay I brought in a list of questions
from the listeners that they wanted me
to ask the ladies so we're gonna carry
on this okay the first question someone
asked is do you like guys to ask you
what you like in bed before they do
things or do you like them to just try
something and see how you feel about it
the example this person gave was a thumb
in the butt thank you for that but I
mean just in general how do you feel
about this hmm
I don't like confidence if the guy seems
confident then I like that so I don't
know we'll see why don't know it's kind
of weird it depends it's like the first
time or is like the second time the
third time the first I was a little
weird if he starts asking things I think
yes I heard yes but agreed it's the
thumb in the butt like I would I would
want a heads up you would yeah I don't
want a heads up oh I do how do you ask
that
you're like a picture you're like like
that stuff I'd probably be now do know
I'm saying if I was asked that question
do you like bud stuff in the middle of
sex wouldn't that totally turn you off
if a guy if you put anything up my butt
yes probably
really I'd probably roll over into the
fetal position and cry really maybe
anything a finger bone maybe if I wasn't
expecting it yeah interesting I don't
like people to ask there's actually a
genre on porn called surprising I'll
really I semble to pocket yeah I did
watch one or two and they did seem very
surprised you just reminded me of
something oh my god you just reminded me
of something okay we should talk about
this the porn guy that I used to date I
dated a program he told me you had a
photo shoot together you're telling me
this yeah by the way if that's his job
is that cheating no we had the same
conversation I couldn't do it because I
like I said I liked any hot guys but I
don't like sharing my men I'm very like
you're like if we're together I don't
want you to be with another girl which
is like I don't know right that's how
it's supposed to be that's how I am but
I just I was that job that's so
interested in Kate would be like oh he's
at work I'm like so you know what he's
doing I did it pretty graphic what they
do I mean he I said it no I
like it I didn't like it it's not like
like honestly when we were dating I kind
of put it out of my head that he did
that I didn't follow him on social media
I didn't look at it I quit watching porn
completely so that I wouldn't
accidentally stumble across him yeah you
know but he would be really good to be
fair to him about like even when he was
on set and stuff on set okay hotel room
in the valley Bakersfield
yeah he would always you know it kind of
texts me throughout the day like he gave
me enough attention to where it didn't
really bother me and I don't know
whatever I I was in denial let's be
honest but what I was gonna say is he
was so good and bad I mean like he would
do [ __ ] for a living and he should be I
know but it's like did he wouldn't award
at that what you hosted in fact when I
met him he was like I'm like the Susan
Lucci of or like I've been nominated
I know but the thing is um one of the
things he would do I'm telling this
story so guys do this because it was
actually really hot cuz one of the
things that made him so good in bed is
that he would constantly be changing it
up I never knew what to expect with him
every time would be different there was
always like a lot of element of surprise
like you said surprise you know I'm not
talking about that I'm not talking about
that
but like for instance like like I come
over his house would be like pitch black
I wouldn't know where he would be and
I'd be like wandering around the house
like hey where are you and he wouldn't
say anything then all of a sudden he'd
like attack me and just start going at
it for instance or or like he'd be like
I'd be on my stomach and he'd be you
know going down on me
right and then he'd be in the middle
going down I mean then all of a sudden
you'd start [ __ ] me like so fast I
don't even know how he went from his
mouth to his dick that quick like I
don't know how you would even do it like
what he sprung up like a burpee like a
sex burpies yeah yeah and so the point
is like the element of surprise though
is so it's so exciting and then the
thing that was great a thing in the dark
would freak me out why is what if you
trip and fall fall one time I like how
that's my way being scary I don't know
you don't want to get hurt have like a
nice and just be a crazy I guess I like
that but I'm into scary stuff like I
like my sex to be mixed with fear a
little no you know I mean I see what you
mean yeah I mean like oh this is
interesting not knowing where like I
would probably just need York reaction
punch him in the face but you know he's
the only one home yeah but still like
that would scare me like he pops out of
a closet or like browse me from behind
yeah it's so hot okay everyone's into
something yeah but guys are taking notes
right now I'm sure Thank You Kate oh my
gosh like okay it's okay like surprise
not every girl likes sex find out what
your girl likes I guess you can tell if
a girl's into that kind of stuff right
what if he came out the longer you're
with someone you kind of get to know
what the weird nicer right yeah they're
queer she you just a chainsaw yeah like
a haunted house and that's how like you
know where he's at like he starts the
chainsaw or something I don't know it
seems very haunted house II well I don't
think I'd be under a chainsaw
I have chainsaws I would cut I write I
am in a knives though I would want to
know like okay so he's in the kitchen I
don't know I'm just trying to brace
myself in case this would ever happen to
me I've never heard of somebody going to
somebody's house and like it's dark and
then like it's so hot house is big so I
get stove approaching or I see like a
ninja like he's no I know he would like
hide in one spot till I walk by I didn't
I didn't seek sex yeah I mean it's super
hot I don't know he's never talked about
his work day oh it was so it was weird
because I would avoid the whole topic of
porn with him yeah like it was not a
thing that after I do the same yeah yeah
but he also didn't talk about it so it
was easy to forget numb right for me so
used to it right for instance there was
the words on there so for us like
talking a lot or I don't know being like
going to a Hollywood event he's like oh
just another day Hollywood event instead
of like
I wonder that about Gaia gynecologist
there we go that's a better example I'm
trying to figure out a way to sing this
ya know it's true though my god you can
turn it on by one and not another yeah I
mean it's actually true you know like he
told me one time that he really liked
hooking up with older women because he's
always hooking up with like super young
girls yeah so I mean I guess I don't
know also it is different you know it's
kind of like if you've ever done a sex
scene in a movie you know it's like
there's so much I mean on porn sets
there's so much stop down literally like
there's so many people watching you I'm
assuming yeah and then we have like oh
yeah right like rips in the director and
then right and then a lot of times
they're all know and lover
there's no fluff or is that a real thing
no I guess that's fake
I heard there's actually no fluffer you
would think though there would need to
be made on occasion there's take pills
oh I'm almost convinced that this guy
took a pill every time we had sex
because he would always ask for a
20-minute heads-up before I got to his
house and like the one time accidentally
forgot he was like oh thanks for the
warning
I'm convinced probably I don't know yeah
anyway all right well I don't know how
we got in how am I still talking about
that guy by the way okay yeah you know
this happens sometimes with when the
girls get together and we took in these
tangents next time I saw a girl show
definitely wine or like some sort of
cocktail emo not even more yeah can we
talk about the rules of spending the
night okay basically yeah the guy that I
was seeing I talked about this on the
last episode but I ended it because well
I ended it and then I kind of went back
and then he ended it but it's done it's
done but because I we hooked up and he
made me leave at 3 a.m. yeah that's rude
thank you he's treating you like a booty
call or he's treating you like like oh I
had what I got what I wanted that's
horrible be so mad that's what I wanna
but that's what I want to know is what
do you think the rules are for spending
the night and what does it mean if you
spend the night like just for it doesn't
have to mean anything but at 3:00 a.m.
and I had a guy asking me to leave at
3:00 a.m. and this is when I lived in
Long Beach which is an hour south of LA
it was like oh my god like it's so late
like I can't just crash here and he was
like no you've got to go he probably as
his girlfriend coming in the morning I I
know I know well that's what I would
think I do yeah so I was like okay like
I'm gonna go I guess I'm like slowly
getting dressed like maybe he'll change
his mind
and he did it and then he starts walking
me outside and I was like oh you don't
have to walk me to the car cuz I'm like
irritated before and he was like no I
need to get my parking pass back from
you my temporary like Guest Pass oh yeah
you don't talk to him anymore right we
didn't talk for a while
don't I'm going through a phase where
I'm trying to just speak like cool with
like guys I've dated or hooked up with
like not to hook up again but just like
I just I don't know I'm just um I don't
even know how to say it like I just want
to be cool with people like I don't it's
weird though because that's a girl
tendency like right I always try to be
cool with everyone I've hooked up with
but don't you ever look back and go why
do I want this person in my life that
week I mean I'm into them sometime
especially if you date people that you
do comedy or you know modeling or
whatever with like if you see each other
I just don't want it to be awkward
that's true but it's always awkward if
it's always awkward when it ends where
one person cared more than the other
that's never gonna be enough time passes
I think you can get over it well that's
for sure yeah well I mean I guess it's
funny because I do a whole bit in my act
about how guys should not cuddle girls
if they don't have feelings for them and
I say you know that they should throw
you out after the sex even though it
hurts in the moment but they're doing
you a favor in the long run because once
you sleep with them it changes your
feelings so I say that and I do believe
that but then when it happened to me and
the guy kicked me out I was pissed as
[ __ ] right and then in my mind I was
like [ __ ] this guy if he doesn't care
about me enough to let me just sleep in
his bed then how can I hang out with him
anymore so I guess now my new thought on
it is if if you have enough feelings for
the guy to where it hurts you when he
doesn't want you to stay and he kicks
you out anyway
then that's got to be a deal-breaker
right I think the end and you even said
you were like I was stressed up because
as girls we
dressed up to go on dates yeah so then
you're walking down stairs and I think
you said you were like in a dress or a
skirt well I was in a body suit and
heels and I was like a shame yeah you
don't want to get dressed but that's
what guys don't understand it's like we
don't want to get back in our nightclub
clothes at 3 o'clock in the morning it
makes you tend to lose things maybe
leave them behind like jewelry oh but
that's the other thing I accidentally
[ __ ] left I left a piece of jewelry
at this guy's house and it's not
expensive it's not important it's
literally like the ring it's like a
twenty dollar ring or something yeah you
know but it sucks because I really
didn't mean to you know how girls so
yeah all he thought you did it on
purpose behind ya I don't know because
in this one instance he actually asked
me to take it off uh-huh you know he was
like uh your ring is kind of yeah yeah
so he was like take it off so I took it
off so it's not like I tried to leave it
behind but then I did and then what's
hilarious is I was like just get rid of
it because I didn't want to see him to
the point of like I don't even want to
see you to get this ring back
you know so I was like just get rid of
it and he's like no I'm not gonna get
rid of it and then we finally met up to
have this like breakup talk where he's
supposed to give me the ring and then
he'd forgot the ring so now he still has
a [ __ ] ring and now we're done and
then today he sent me a photo of the
ring it's like the horror movie the ring
mind games
oh the ring is gone all right well so
but the question is do you think because
this is for the male listeners do you
think there's ever a time when it's okay
for the guy to ask you to leave
well I I don't think it's a it's polite
in a sense like okay if you guys are
being intimate and you do your thing
even if it's casual yeah even its casual
you guys have been talking dating and
then you just kicks you out like at 3:00
a.m. it's kind of unless it's your
choice unless you're like I'll have to
be at the office I'd of course I mean
that's different but if he just says it
and like oh hey I think it's time for
you to go
it is kindest respectful because he kind
of just he shows you that you were just
something he needs
quick fix right and that's not cool like
we're all human beings right we're not a
quick fix yet so no bueno no bueno
oh I agree I think the only time I never
I never asked to spend the night by the
way unless I'm legitimately tired it's
not like I'm like really like it's just
weird it's a weird situation but I know
you mean it's like that respect thing
right yeah yeah
if it's just strictly a booty call
though if it's literally a guy I guess
one-night stands I guess it'll be kind
of weird right like yeah a one-night
stand
well actually the only time don't you
have it no I've never I've only had two
I've only had two and one was amazing so
great oh I guess three if you count the
guy that my god we'd be way before we
close out tell this story I told it on
here last week but it's great I forgot
about that one but it's not really a
one-night stand I guess I knew him first
okay okay already but uh anyway I if
it's a one-night stand though usually
I'm drunk which is even more reason you
would spend the night right a hundred
percent I don't know you're gonna her
home but like you said if you live far
like Long Beach thought that's yeah yeah
no bueno
um what is the worst date you've ever
been on have you ever had an awful
experience that was just so terrible yes
actually too many nights it's the one
that always kind of stays my mind it's
hilarious I was in college I went to LMU
and this guy took me out on a date he
was like this model he shows up in like
this old-school limo like 87 limo and I
was like why am I about to get murdered
wait was he driving it yeah he was gonna
like hip and retro so I was putting like
the puzzle pieces together I was like
maybe there's like a cool thing we're
gonna do like a theme of the show I
don't know but no you know what always
interesting so this model dude was a
character so anyways I ended the day I
was like I feel like I'm I'm about to
get murdered like it was weird and then
he started to talk he was talking about
random conspiracies it was weird mind
you I've known the guy for a while like
through the industry so I totally saw a
different side of him and I was like oh
I have class in the morning mm-hmm got
to go and I felt but he got mad but I
was like gotta go power walk power what
power walk so do you think he was
feeling it you know I don't know I don't
know if he forgot to his crazy pills or
something but it was definitely off I
needed like a GoPro on my shoulder this
could've made could have made my career
right here it could've been a YouTube
star posting this on you did I think
that all we're probably like waiting for
Ashton Kutcher did like jump at like oh
[ __ ]
oh my god that would have been oh and
then the limo had like like junk food
like like he just came back from like in
and out all over it was weird
it was weird mind you the guy was really
good-looking clean-cut it smelled good
and everything but he was just a little
cuckoo I was like I gotta go back pretty
ones are usually pretty crazy
right how about this I went out with a
guy the other night I totally forgot
about this is a great date fail I went
out the guy the other night we met up uh
it was kind of a last-minute thing I ran
into him somewhere and it's a guy that I
know we've gone out before and so he
happened to have uber there and I have
my car and he's like hey you want to go
somewhere and like get food and I was
like yeah
so I drive he picks the place we go to
this spot in Beverly Hills and there's a
meter and I pull up to the meter and
it's late it's like 11:00 happen and I
go to him hey do I need to feed this
meter and he was like oh no you're good
when we go in we hang out for an hour or
two whatever we come back out and have a
parking ticket and this [ __ ] did
not offer to pay the parking ticket
probably couldn't afford the $68 did he
pay for your dinner he probably thought
oh I paid for her food actually I didn't
even eat actually in hindsight now that
I think about it it was like such a
selfish date because one the kitchen was
closing but the guy you know he has
money so he said to them like and he
does have money so he said to them like
hey is there any way you can make me
something I'm really hungry I'll pay
I'll pay extra for that so they like
made him something but I didn't get
anything which was fine because I wasn't
really hungry but then also I'm not a
wine drinker and this place didn't even
have liquor it just had fear of mine so
then I I was like I like wine but I'm
really allergic to it like I get really
bad hangovers from it but so then that
was my only option so basically what I'm
saying is it wasn't a great day I had to
drink what I didn't want and then I got
a $60 parking ticket he didn't offer to
pay for it and I didn't say he said it
was okay I would have been annoyed right
and that's what people with money do
they're just like oh if I get a ticket
like no big deal I'll pay it tomorrow
they don't understand when you're on a
budget world of a struggling artist
no but that's happening actually to me
one time really it was actually a guy
that I was dating for a while and I got
a parking ticket because of him and he
was driving my car mind you and he
didn't pay for it
isn't that horrible he was driving my
car that before and I didn't know there
was like tickets and then all of a
sudden I got like at all these
collection notices happen more than once
what a douche right crazy to me I should
mail the guys i would pay for if i was
driving my boyfriend's car i would even
pay for it if I was on a date here and
the guy said do I need to if I'm the one
that read the sign and then he got a
ticket or a yeah wouldn't you yeah for
his Carrie have you had any bad dates
recently any terrible story he has one
where I went out with a guy who was a
recovering alcoholic and so when we were
at dinner I was like oh joy drink do I
not drink but I was like well I don't
want to curb my not drinking because he
doesn't want to drink so I probably had
like three glasses of wine and by the
third one and I saw him he kept like
looking down at it and all of a sudden
he's like hold on and he goes outside
and he called his sponsor and then he
had a sponsor pick him up Wow
yeah did he even tell you he was leaving
I think he like texted me oh yeah hacks
to do it was a nice restaurant and I
actually don't mind eating alone so it
was fine did you pay no well I mean when
you don't order alcohol the bill is
cheaper that's true I mean I guess to be
fair to have no props to him for leaving
and not mean
hard to be an alcoholic yeah I wasn't
angry but I didn't talk to him again I
mean obviously a relationship when it
works out thing is I hate it when people
do that like texting liked it like Oh
like they don't say body to your face
like they just text it depends what the
girlfriend be like someone's dating like
that's very sad oh I was dating a guy
one time and we weren't exclusive it
wasn't serious at all in fact I still
see this guy but like it's just one of
those situations it's funny I was joking
about it because this guy has not the
best reputation but for some reason he
and I have the most healthy situation
maybe that I've ever had with my it's so
hairy everyone's why I see him you went
through that you worked through the
kinks we had some nerves for a moment
because I expect things at the beginning
yeah because at the beginning I always
expect every guy to to treat me like you
know pretty he's Prince Charming or
whatever but then once I see how someone
works if it's for instance like with
this guy he sometimes doesn't text me
back which normally makes me crazy but
with him I don't ever think it's
malicious and if I were to text him
again just be like hey um what's up you
didn't answer my texts he'd be like oh
I'm so sorry I was legitimately he's
just a busy flighty we don't have a
strong enough connection to where I
think it's gonna be anything more than
what it is but every once while we hang
out we hook up the sex is good it's not
mind-blowing but I enjoy his company's
handsome he treats me well whatever so
hey it's good you know you're in the
perfect situation yeah and that's a
that's a unicorn of a situation because
I think it's tough especially well for
most girls but especially you to not
catch feelings and I mean that in a nice
way
yeah I forget why I started that story
but you know it doesn't matter the point
is I have a good situation with that one
so damn I wish I remember why I brought
that up he popped in your mind
I [ __ ] up that story that's a great
ending it's a great ending to a podcast
I want you guys to plug your stuff one
more time please tell people where they
can find you so I'm which camera do I
look at there's like two three whichever
one you feel yeah so I'm
it's you need some when you have spelled
y en itz a who knows m un o z my name is
crazy okay guys a little local but
anyway so yes you need something else is
my IG my facebook my snapchat my twitter
it's it's everything so yes you need
some who knows you can look at all my my
Maxim photos I guess Thank You Kate for
the shout out on that I also have photos
of beautiful Kate on there we do like to
chill him out and he did do a photo
shoot together that Sports Illustrated
Illustrated and shout out so it's pretty
awesome
ya know that day we should have talked
about that that they was so cold we were
out in the Malibu in the winter rollin
in the sand like tryin to be hot and
sexy it was really I was like my lips
were shaking I was like models haven't
really enough do not dying I shot an axe
commercial one time and it was same
thing it was Malibu and we're in bikinis
and it was like January yeah that's when
we had her she was like January February
oh yeah but at least our shoot we were
kind of laying like where the water was
just coming in although I did end up
getting drenched but like for the
actuator like go frolic in the waves
like you're pretending it's like July it
was so cold I'm not exaggerating
people's lips were turning purple
to the point where the makeup artist
couldn't do anything about it and they
were like we'll fix him in post like
they had to turn people's lips back to
pink and posed because it was so cold I
have a snapchat I should post yeah I
throw back whatever what days is
Thursday yeah throwback of her running
around like it's so cool funny I was
like I'm in my 30s and I'm doing this it
was things we do man yeah things we -
yeah
carry to be cool I'm just going to plug
in Itza so you can find her on source TV
yes so chewy and Ganesa yes and can they
vote for you on maximized yes so right
now I'm part of the contacts contest
Maxim's finest I have six days to win
I'm number nine for the West Coast
division so please vote for me just go
to Maxim's finest calm and click on my
photo you need some munos number
please I would love to win it would be
amazing love everyone yes when is that
over in six days so perfect yes keep
voting for me I'm gonna take everyone
out to dinner all my close friends
taking you out too cuz I just met you
know I would love that homie no but is
it just one vote like a one and done or
one a day one a day six days yeah he's
on my Instagram story I posted the link
for your needs uh so go vote and guys
this has been date fails I think what we
learned today is girl right I said I'll
get on yeah don't just don't kick them
out that's really the gist of it don't
kick them out although I do say you
should if you don't have real feelings
for them but how about if you don't have
real feelings for them don't [ __ ] them
that's not gonna work that's not gonna
happen
alright well anyway this has been Dave
fails I love you guys please go to my
patreon and sponsor the show if you're a
fan it's patreon.com
that's why she has a parking ticket to
pay for Thank You patreon.com backslash
Kate cue funny I love you guys see you
next time bye